opinions create adversaries I always say
I like can talk about is knowledge for
me and whether you agree with that I
don't give a [ __ ] there's nothing to do
with it yeah you know what I mean like I
just give you my knowledge from me if
you say well that's not true I'll go
okay it's true for me so what what does
it matter what like you think but we
have come to this weird place where
everybody feels like their thing is the
right thing so that's why when people
ask me I go no no let me just tell you
what I do
and what works for me someone might hear
you eat the same thing every day and go
that's not enough nutrients that's not
enough this and I go okay
it works for me right like I'm okay like
I don't again
I've never been one to seek out like I
like to listen to people and I like to
hear their thoughts and then but like I
had to as I get older and you and I know
this it's like I started shedding away
the things that don't work for me and
the things that work for me so right now
you're saying you have anxiety that
you'd like to get past
okay
what Avenues are you going to try to do
that you can't just go one way you got
to try a month oh I'm trying a lot of
different things you're right you're
right I'm trying hypnotism I'm about to
start I'm trying energy therapy I'm
trying micro dosing I'm trying meds and
trying just trying to do everything
that I can to live the best life I can
and you're gonna find the one and it's
gonna be the thing for you and then
someone's gonna go what the [ __ ] would
you do that try this instead try this
try this go jump out of a plane wearing
a [ __ ] furry costume and you're gonna
like be way better and you go what I
know this works for me and that's
everybody has their thing and they think
they want people to come and believe in
it so it reassures that their thing is
the right thing and this is why what I
say I don't know people go oh you're a
vegan I go sure right now maybe not
tomorrow I don't I don't know and I
think that when you start
we want to box people so bad on things
on everything and I'm just like
I always say this and it gets people
weird I'm like I don't even exist like I
exist as in
when I'm a dad I'm with my kids when I'm
with my dog I'm Theo with the dog I'm
Theo as the dad I'm Theo talking to you
on this amazing podcast I'm
it I'm Theo when I see you at Comic-Con
like I'm that per but I'm never who am I
am I'm just someone playing the role
that I'm in
so
I don't [ __ ] have I'm not I'm not my
feet aren't in concrete on anything
except one thing just don't be an
[ __ ]
simply